okay everyone so this
is my spoiler review of sweet tooth
season one
if you haven't watched every episode of
this season please come back
after you've watched every episode i
will be talking about every single
episode and spoilers ahead of time
so make sure you are finished with the
season before you watch this
so i'm going to break down every single
episode and give a raid in each episode
then i'll give my final season
score so episode one is directed and
written by jim mickel who is the
showrunner
of sweet tooth so at first i was a
little hesitant about the narration here
i feel like we've heard this type of
narration 100 times over
where he's like some stories start at
the beginning but this one starts here
but it grew on me as a show went on and
it worked more and more
but this episode was really effective
because hey it had a lot of will forte
but b it really sets the stage
for this character of gus and this world
we're in
and it's really has a lot of intrigue
right out of the gate
literally this episode feels like it
could have been its own movie it was so
good
and having you be already invested so
fast into this relationship
with his father pogba and then in the
same episode have pogba pass away
and then have us meet really his next
father figure
in big man was really well done and i
still think this is the best episode of
the whole season and i love that we see
that big man gave gus his nickname of
sweet tooth
but i love our character of gus who had
such an overbearing father and very
protective father
he makes the leap by the end of this
episode to jump over the fence right and
think what if
my father was wrong and he actually has
to grow up quicker than most children
obviously losing his father living in
this type of world
and it really focuses so well on our
main character we learned so much about
him one episode
and to have all those beats hit like i
said it really does feel like a movie
where
you get introduced to the character you
get emotionally attached you have
tragedy happen but then you have growth
and it all happens here
and what works well with the show is
that in this first episode
he's getting information about his
mother possibly being out there
and what makes it exciting is it sets
the journey here
it's exactly how you want to do a
fantasy adventure show
and i love this moment where he's like
big man take me and he makes that
decision
and it has a good interesting character
of big man aka jefford because
jeopard is someone who has this wall to
him
and he's got a lot of skeletons in his
closet right and demons he's dealing
with
and it's slowly over time the show gus
breaking through that tough man
and just at the base of it we haven't
had many fantasy shows that
go into more hopeful setting a more
cheery setting and this is a breath of
fresh air because so many shows want to
be like game of thrones and do the dark
fantasy
so this is like coming i think at the
perfect time and
i think that if you're looking at it
writing wise again they already
emotionally attach it to your main
characters and there's a goal set
so we know our journey now he's gonna go
try to find his mom and it's setting it
up to be an adventure right for that
doesn't waste time
so i'm giving this first episode a 9.8
so episode two sorry about all the dead
people is directed
again by jim mikkel and this time it's
written by jim michael and beth schwartz
who also works on arrow
so this is where we first meet amy and
we see this really cool flashback of her
and her mundane life and then it
changing when she
actually sees these elephants and it's
setting up her life to be this zookeeper
but in a future
timeline and really making the preserve
and i like that you know she's setting
this bird free
just symbolism of herself setting
herself free from this day-to-day life
she's had and this is the start of us
meeting this new character and i like
they kept up with this pattern and
having introductions of characters be
the intro of episodes but very brief
what i love about episode two in the
present day is that
it really leans into gus's deer side and
that we see how his ears interact
everything which i thought was one of
the best things about the show
and even the jokes they make about his
eyes glowing in the dark and the
family's a little freaked out by that i
love they kept such
truth to him being half dear and even
his sense of smell being really high and
great hearing
and you'll see jokes layered throughout
the episode and shows like that about
him
hearing people whispering about him
because he has super hearing and i love
the little boy of this house they
arrived to ask him if he poops pellets i
thought that was actually really funny
and even when he tickles him he acts
like a deer the way he reacts i thought
that was so good too
so what i really like though is we
really get now into dr
singh's story addie and he's with his
wife ronnie who has the sick
but it's setting up well which will get
pay off by the end of the season about
him not feeling able to really make the
cure that's been set for him to make
because it goes against everything he
believes morally hurting these hybrids
that are still half children he
acknowledges that
addie is actually a human here and has a
soul and he's
someone again we can gravitate to right
away so likable and the actor is really
likable
and they keep such good mystery with
addy's storyline that
they only show you little bits each
episode like you see there's a book of
stuff that he doesn't believe in but we
don't see it right away what he's seeing
so it did a good job of keeping you
invested into the show and it was smart
like all these characters are a little
gray especially tommy and they keep
hinting at
their stuff we don't know about him and
you learn as this show goes on more
about
what those skeletons in the closet are
but
that the character will then grow and
learn from that and become a different
person
and we learned too through gus's lens
which worked really well is how
sheltered he was as a kid
and slowly learning more about how much
his father lied to him and that goes
with here even learning about
he didn't create these original books
right he was just kind of making copies
and that there wasn't actually fires
everywhere and i also like the touch in
this episode where
gus sees the other boy rusty with his
mom and how good of a mom she is and
that
something he wishes he had and gus
already struggling here with
trying to feel normal and always feeling
weird already being a hybrid but
not really having parents i love though
this sequence was so exciting with the
last men showing up to this house
trying to get gus and this family
protects him i actually want to see more
of this family in season two i thought
especially the mom was a really just
really good character honestly and
i think that the best line of this
episode goes to the title episode
where rusty gives gus this sweater he's
like sorry i called you weird and gus
is like sorry about all the dead people
i thought that was absolute gold
and the episode ends on a nice payoff
for the setup with amy
where this new opportunity this new life
starts for her
by wendy who is pigtail another hybrid
was given to her
and it changed her whole life and her
starting
this preserve so what i loved about
these first two episodes is it was
really good at giving you
solid writing with meaning and each
scene counts
and there's sad hopeful suspense funny
all blended into one which i think
always makes hits
right that's what people like to see the
most a little bit of everything and so
far they do that really well it's a nice
blend of different tones but this
episode continues
where i really love the show in
particular so i'm gonna give it a nine
point two
so episode three weird dear [ __ ] is
directed by
alexis ostrander and written by michael
r perry this is where the quality went
down a little bit for me
still really enjoying it but this is
where we get introduced to bear for the
first time in this group of kids
this group of kids reminds me of the
lost boys from the hook film
just the way they dress the way they act
you almost feel like you're arriving at
neverland here
i want to point out some camera work i
loved in this episode there's a moment
where gus is laying on this bus
and the camera faces him and tilts and
the breath gets cold turning to a snowy
morning but it's really all a nightmare
sequence
i thought that was so well done visually
and some really good lines here also
with
addy's character in this episode and him
saying it was recorder
i'm reminded why i quit being a doctor
time of choosing who to
live and who to die so that pressure he
had and why he didn't like doing what he
did anymore
and it's really just ramming into this
conflict addie's feeling where
if this saves the world does the ends
justify the means in what this doctors
left him to do to make this cure or
should he still stick to his morals here
but i really like ronnie's wife saying
to him if there's anyone who could find
a humane
alternative it's you addie and you
really like this relationship between
the two of them
especially that bond they have with
scrabble but where stuff gets
really really crazy and pretty dark
probably the darkest the show gets
is when they go to this party and you
see what this life is like in this world
now
and that they're not telling anyone
about
ronnie having the sick but they know
she's not contagious remember that
that the doctor knows that's dr singh
and it's just crazy that this guy
has the sick at this party and they burn
him alive
so crazy now i did feel the
jeopard and gus story trying to get on
this train dragged a little bit when
they're at the train station throughout
this episode but it picked up at the end
i love the lie when they're trying to
run away from the last men and
shepherds like get your damn ears under
control that was great
but they end up getting caught by the
last man but then our group from the
hook films
saves shepherd and gus it leaves a nice
cliffhanger to who
this group really is what are they about
and it also has a nice hook here
or general abbott our main villain who
looks like eggman from
sonic he's looking at the board and he
sees his preserved note and that they
found her so he's already getting on to
amy i'm gonna give this one an 8.4 still
very solid just not as
amazing as the first two but that's hard
to live up to so episode four is secret
sauce
directed by toa frazier and written by
justin boyd and hayley harris
what i did really find interesting about
bear's crew
is that they were about to shoot jeopard
like they had no patience for anyone who
was ever involved with the last men
but gus is able to talk them down and he
does that throughout this episode
it will also have him get closer to
jeopard this way that jetberg really
starts to really like us here
now where i was a little turned off was
that i
loved meeting wendy and pigtail with amy
here and she's literally all excited
they're gonna go shopping and she makes
that pig squeal which was amazing that
was just an
awesome moment i think fans are gonna
love that i actually wanted more of that
more of them embracing some of these
hybrid sci that they originally were
doing with gus a lot in the beginning
that would seem more kind of even pig
stuff
from pigtail but i didn't really
dig this whole bobby character in this
cutesy gopher that appears it's just
full-on gopher i thought it still was
even a little
confusing about what his deal really was
or what his purpose really was he just
kind of felt like he was there to be the
really cute
again this tropes be coming out of this
this baby type character baby yoda baby
mr peanut it's everywhere now they're
making the baby marshmallow steak puff
man from
ghostbusters in the new film so it's
non-stop and this just felt like it was
reaching for that
cutie feeling even with the music and
how it ended this episode was a little
off with them ending with the gopher of
bobby and i also felt
that amy and pigtail's storyline wasn't
that thick like there wasn't a lot of
meat to the bone here that
we got little glimpses of it and then it
just kind of
got more intense by the end but i still
didn't feel like they had enough screen
time and when they did
it really didn't do much to move the
needle and to learn more about them it
kind of just
stayed static i also had a big problem
in this episode when
basically it seems like bear has decided
to have
jeopard sent to this death sentence but
what didn't make sense was
you see they have all these people in
this group of bears and they're all in
their different costumes which are cool
like the set cops are cool it's cool
that guy was dressed up as like a zebra
but i wasn't crazy about this misdirect
right it felt so lame that
she brought everyone out there and it
was just a tease for her to be like
but we aren't going to do it like not
kill this guy
but she already made up her mind before
she got to the podium
so why not make her make that decision
in choice in that big character moment
and change during the moment that she
was going there to kill him but then
right before she's about to kill him
then she changes her mind like it just
felt corny and weird and didn't make
sense it
took away the tension and it just felt
like a decision
that only hurts the scene like keep the
suspensor that we don't know what she's
gonna do
and then have her make that decision on
the podium and it just felt silly when
they all started fighting the song here
didn't work
i didn't like the whole wrestling thing
and they tried to squeeze in this real
tiger under this other character's tiger
we barely got any time with to kind of
get
more of but they did tease her towards
the end that should be important so
i don't know i thought this was probably
the worst scene of the whole show
and i also thought it was really weird
as we had this scene that was really
good with the neighbor nancy of
addie's and she's on to addie and his
wife right
and she's laying into them about ronnie
possibly being sick but then the scene
kind of ends
and then all of a sudden like it feels
like a scene's missing because she
magically is just
back there and is super pissed in the
same moment
and now is laying into them and then
this horse kicks her that was where
i feel like a show you know has to avoid
being silly like this because again the
main character
is half deer so you want to make it that
it's taken seriously
and that people really like it not get
turned off by it and i just felt like
this episode was just
the one episode of the whole season i'd
say it's just completely silly and could
be a turn off for people it just felt
totally off of the rest of the season
especially those first couple episodes
i wasn't hot about it so i'm going to
give this one a 6.9 okay so episode five
what's in the freezer
directed by rob and grace and written by
christina hamm but we learned more about
the general here by him visiting gladys
the original doctor
working on this cure and that the
general will do
anything to get rid of this virus he
doesn't care who it hurts
that's what makes him a villain he has
no morals so we also get this valley of
sorrows
scene going on this episode of gus and i
thought they set it up like there's
gonna be something really cool
but it wasn't that great i mean he gets
a vision of pueblo which is predictable
and it's kind of a scene you've seen in
so many things before
and that character giving him advice and
i thought it could have been a little
crazier and a little more creative it
looked really nice though
but really worked for me as where i felt
in this part of the season that
gus shepard and bear's story was kind of
falling flat a bit
i still think that addie's story here
was really good and that
i love his speech the neighborhood out
they're all hypocrites
and this is happening when addie and
ronnie are tied up here the neighbors
are about to burn them alive
i love this point of view shot it was
pure horror when they're seeing the
neighbors singing at them and
it ironically happens that the last men
actually saved their lives by trying to
capture them but i thought this was
really good
this scene but the episode as a whole
was decent but again even the amy stuff
here just falls flat as well
and feeling like there wasn't a super
amount of payoff in the gus
valley sorrow scene so i'm gonna give
this one still an 8.1 it still was solid
but again not the best
so episode six stranger danger on a
train this was written by
noah griffith and daniel stewart and was
directed by show runner jim mickel
so this episode is when they actually
get on this train right and this is
what i not my favorite type of episode
of shows they're necessary it's just
transitional episodes literally when
characters
moving from one point to the other we
got to get to the big resolution of the
show now
and again they're literally on a train
but it felt a little heavy on the sap
here
and wasn't the best writing when
published again with bear and she's
talking about she had a sister
at that point it felt a little too much
of that right like we wanted to get on
with the action here
but we see that jeopard recognized the
crewmen on this train
jimmy right and we see which i did like
because these candy bars on the train so
you know
it's last men's car because using those
candy bars is bait for the hybrids
but where the writings to telly here is
when jimmy's like
i don't remember you being like that
you're always for yourself talking about
jeopard when he says he cares about the
kid
i would have actually like to see more
that which we do see with shepard by the
end
of this season but here it just felt
forced
now what my problem was in this sequence
was jeopard sees the dog is in front of
the last minute on the train right when
the last men show up
and it's a really exciting scene but he
actually risks
really everyone for this dog doll for
gus
and it actually ends up getting jimmy
killed because if he didn't do that they
could have just all ran on the train and
got away
so i think that was something he could
have avoided where i get what they were
going for
right and it would pay off again in the
finale that he'd given the dog and how
important that was for gus knowing
that's all he had left of his dad but i
just think they had to
shift it around a little differently the
blocking that didn't make it seem like
wait a minute
he just did that and now jimmy's dead
maybe not even have jimmy die
and i didn't like either i hate when
shows feel like they're emulating
something that just happened
and having jimmy hold the door and
sacrifice himself was literally
ripped out of game of thrones with hodor
and hold the door same beats
and this was the one episode i felt the
narration didn't even really sink well
and work well about the letting go
that the narrator is talking about and
this was one of the thinner episodes to
me story-wise and again
amy stuff ramped up a bit here but it's
really just placing amy
and pig dale to be where they need to be
for the last two episodes but i'm gonna
give this one a 7.3
so where the show started getting back
to the quality of episode one and two
for me was episode seven
when pubmed birdie this was directed by
toa frazier written by beth schwartz
again it's always gonna be ramped up too
because you got will forte back in the
fold here
but in flashback form i love the
chemistry he had here with
birdie i like this story that it was
just a date they were on they weren't
actually a married couple
i thought that was a nice refreshing
twist to a story we've seen a lot of
times this setup when you go flashbacks
you know like that birdie was directly
connected being a scientist
to hybrids being created and making the
first one in gus so you get all these
big
information out and payoffs right and
the still mystery looming of
the connection of the hybrids to the
sick what came first they still kind of
have that going
and there's nice touches here cutting
from present day
to flashback and back and forth where
you see that birdie
and pabba were at this sal's bar and in
present day
that's where gus and bear and jeopard
start the episode at but i really like
they leaned into bear and shepard
being concerned that they are close to
where gus thinks his mom's going to be
but they know rios because she's
probably not even there
i love that when they get to this house
they meet this character judy
who used to be friends with birdie but
when gus is like she's not even living
here is she and his ears go down i
thought that was perfect
and i also love when he sees the picture
of his mom
with his grandpa and he says to jeopard
grandpappa jeff i have a grandpa
i thought that was so good and it was
cool and having this intrigue and then
going the attic finding these folders
and that gus
was genetic unit service one that's what
it stands for
and it's such a heartbreaking scene
seeing him learn about his true
origin and the stuff here in the
flashback was still really exciting
seeing birdie
and pogba escaping this lab that was
raided by the military and how
papa ended up with gus and in gus being
so heartbroken it really shows the
growth of shepard and bear here and how
they have to comfort
gus and makes everybody really likable
here which is always good
and this is where the narration really
worked where he says sometimes the truth
hurts sometimes those answers leave us
more in the dark than ever
and gus lands on his knees this is what
i'm talking about where the meat on the
bone comes back this is
good storytelling good television feels
like they're all the episodes
back invested again so i give this one
an 8.9 for sure
now here we go to the finale and a lot
of netflix shows recently haven't had
great finales to be honest but this was
one of the best
this one's titled big man and this was
directed and written by
showrunner jim mickel who seems like
he's doing the best episodes for sure
and really what i loved about this was
the flashbacks with
jeopard oh my god let's just give a
shout out to the actor nanzo
and noonsie here he crushes it and you
recognize him from game of thrones
but this is going to be his really big
breakout performance he's so good
but him seeing in the flash back that he
possibly had a hybrid as a kid and he
was so concerned he was so judgmental at
the time
and him just this tragic end where he
was on this elevator and then he was
about to leave his wife and his kid when
he found out it was a goat
baby and he decided to make the decision
then to go back and do the right thing
because of love for the child and it was
too late
heartbreaking but it makes it explain
so well why he is the ways when we first
meet him
and why he'd have it in him to come
around to gus
i'm gonna give another actor shout out
here it's gonna go to the actor who
plays
general abbott neil sandylands crushes
it here
when he's with abby as such nuance to it
when he's talking about the new wave of
sick coming
i don't just want any cure i want the
only cure he's horrifying he sells it
and what i mean by nuance is it's hard
to not play that type of villain
over the top or cheesy and he does it
perfectly you take him seriously and
he's scary
and you see him as a real person too
which is important he's not like a
cartoon villain
but what i love this finale does is that
everybody
is split up and then there's new
pairings happening setting up season two
where eventually
jeopard loses gus amy loses
the hybrids and like they come together
because of it gus and amy and they want
to get their kids back perfect except
for season two
and that gus will meet these hybrids
perfect for season two this is how you
do a finale this is how you hook people
in to come back and still give enough
payoffs in one episode
but that was the best moment in this
series was when jeopard
has this long monologue with gus and gus
has opened him about feeling
the weird one and not having a dad and
this is where jeopard really
becomes this new man taking the shield
off and opening up to gus who he loves
how important was to hold on to that dog
and that line fear was love
i didn't know what to do with so great
great
thematically message your lines that
stick with you
and that line he said too i heard a lot
of people i don't mean to hurt them
sometimes i just make bad decisions you
know what i think you're
one of the good ones that's the best
line of the show for me he says to gus
and he says don't make me lose you too
that was
so so good and really just a huge payoff
and
that was wild when he got shot that
freaked me out scared me shocked me
really really exciting stuff
and we get this big reveal that bear her
baby sister
is pigtail so that was another
connection we're gonna have which is
exciting to see where that goes
and her mention like i said before that
her and tiger used to be really close
and she felt betrayed by tiger so that's
also setting something up with that crew
and then it's exciting cliffhanger or
two or bear makes the call on the phone
to alaska and it ends up being
birdie she is alive but like i said what
makes this finale so good
everyone's kind of at their worst
situation now
it's heightened conflict to make you
excited to come back to the show now i
i want to watch season two right now and
it's not out unfortunately that's what
you want you want to get people excited
on the edge of their seat
and you have these new character
pairings which is exciting to see it
already feels fresh
and hasn't even started yet season two
so i'm giving the finale a 9.4 i thought
it was excellent
so as a whole i'm gonna give the show an
8.7 it would be higher
right if you look at it i really think
the first two episodes in the last two
episodes were the best
hands down different level of show just
quality all around
where i felt the middle got like i said
a little silly a little sloppy
um and i'm not sure how i feel about
this gopher i'm not trying to be biased
here but
i don't know what the deal is of bobby
what is the point to this character
let me know though what you guys thought
of this show as a whole if you're gonna
be coming back for season two if you
liked it
any comments i love to hear your
thoughts i read every comment and try to
respond to as many
as i can please make sure to check out
my celebrity interviews i interviewed
some of the members of the cast so
you're going to want to see that
and please make sure to check out my
other reviews i do i do a bunch of tv
shows and movies
you can follow me at steve varley show
on twitter instagram and tick tock for
more of me
and if you really like what i do here i
have membership you can join down below
it will really help me in so many ways
you get exclusive perks on each tier so
make sure to check that out as well
and i'll see you next